wear what you're going to use at the
interview in advance and be comfortable
make sure that your handshake is proper
sat uppr good posture eye contact but
you are not staring them
down the human body is always
transmitting the question is who is
receiving that
information the interview really starts
before the interview outside the door
already when someone hands in a CV or
their social media when you're parking
your car are you taking a space that is
not allowed are you greeting the
security person that is standing there I
remember going to an interview once and
the person that was going to interview
me was in the elevator with me sometimes
I give uh CEOs the advice sit down on
that reception stool and observe the
person who's coming in because then you
can also already see how they're
treating reception staff we assess each
other in milliseconds not even seconds
it's not just your body language or
facial expressions it's everything that
communicates some people are making
already judgments you have to make a
good impression first by understanding
that you have to make a good impression
selling yourself you're promoting
yourself so that's why you need to be
confident and be perceived as
trustworthy as well as competent know
what you're going to say what they're
going to ask you prepare prepare prepare
you don't have a copy of your CV and
they refer to it you now look less
prepared and if you hand it to somebody
hand it with value if you do it like
this you know bit of the turtleneck like
that completely different than this is
who I am and this is what I've done in
life as I walk into the room I have to
remember that I have to be respectful of
that room always make yourself known so
you walk up to them you shake hands can
can I sit here yes you can sit here I
have to make eye contact with everybody
in that room and that I have to treat
everybody equally and not focus on the
chair that you want to sit in but focus
on the people that are present in that
room as you make your introduction I
want to hear a strong voice I want to
see an upright posture I want to see the
chin up confidence No Hands In Pockets I
want to see your hands I want to see you
ready to engage in an interaction I will
shake everybody's hands equally I'm not
just going to focus on the highest
status person or or the
leader if you ask most people have you
ever had a bad handshake they yeah we
all have had those awful handshakes yeah
it was wet week this that whatever if we
are meeting up for the first time we
align ourselves and that we have a short
handshake usually it's like this if
you're giving me a very light handshake
I don't want to be grabbing at the
knuckles if you're giving me a really
strong handshake I I don't want to give
you a loose handshake back I'm going to
try and match your level of grip
especially when you're a woman I've had
so many bad handshakes because of the
strength that men probably want to
portray I still don't understand people
try and dominate a handshake never try
and dominate a handshake but what we do
see a lot too long and they keep shaking
like this all the time or they hold the
hand which makes it very uncomfortable
or they probe the hand which is the like
the finger like that keep all of my
fingers is below your wrist so up to the
point where they touch you here or here
or even here and that we would not
advise unless I know you very well it's
like hey how are you you know then it's
like oh so good to see you great humans
impress first visually then vocally tone
of voice then verbally and the last is
haptics through touch the brain
cataloges all this negative
stuff you have to let them set the stage
and the rules don't talk over them turn
yielding does this person ever shut up
some people start talking immediately hi
I'm here for the job and they start
selling themselves take a breath you
know what you're doing and speak
comfortably depending on how many people
you're talking to I would always wait
just to let them take up the moment of
interaction and to tell them what they
want from you show you are engaged you
are actively listening and you are in
the interaction present use your hands
and use your face to emphasize as
they're talking I want you to be nodding
along with what they're saying not too
much that you look like a Bubblehead you
want to have a slight head tilt when
you're talking to them especially when
you're trying to show empathy when
people ask a question make sure you
answer it don't be so busy talking that
you are not aware that you've been asked
a question I want to see you orientated
towards them because orientation
Behavior shows interest don't pick at
your clothing don't pick out lint and so
forth don't pring yourself even because
they are uncomfortable you might see a
self hug you know those kind of things
and we so do not advise that the best
conversations take place with comfort
for both parties I'm overly sat with my
shoulders back and my chest out trying
to be really really upright I look like
a robot if you are very comfortable like
that that is not that's not a good
portraying you will feel in your body
when it feels unnatural listen to
yourself feel comfortable and it should
feel natural everybody knows this but a
lot of people don't do it don't be
caught off guard with any question have
a trial interview have somebody just ask
you a few questions and see how you come
across and if you're clearing your
throat and you have to hesitate for too
long people don't like that hesitation
is a
killer always say thank you show them
respect expect by showing them you are
grateful for their time expect to you
know say goodbye and Shake Hands maybe
hand out a card if not you can just nod
validate everybody that you had the
opportunity this is the last time you
have a chance to influence remember the
interview is only over when you are
completely out of sight you leave the
room with proactiveness and a posture
that shows you're active or that you are
energetic to go for what you want to go
often if you feel that it went really
well people can completely relax and
they don't walk out the room with as
much confidence or as much Poise as they
came in the room you're only done after
you're back in your car home so maintain
that confidence level maintain that
posture maintain that Poise into are
fully out of the
room when it comes to Virtual
interaction you actually at an advantage
there's actually a lot more control is
the lighting good is the sound okay many
people have learned the hard way not to
use the camera that came with her
computer go out and buy that or borrow a
decent 4k camera you are in complete
control of your virtual space so you can
make sure that it's tidy that you don't
have things that are drawing attention
away there was somebody applying for a
high-end job and in the background there
was only liquor it might be in his
kitchen so you can say oh yeah well he's
got liquor in his kitchen but we pick up
on the liquor first and in our brain we
make an association eye contact is
really important virtually you just have
to remember that everything is now
exaggerated your gestures are now
reduced to 27 in that's what most
cameras capture they can't look at the
rest of your body so there's going to be
more emphasis on the face the other
difficult thing with zoom is the
technique so we have sometimes a delay
of a question and that feels awkward
sometimes like can I talk already or not
and you see the hesitation the turn
yielding is a bit delayed that can can
throw the interview interviewee or the
interviewer off so I have to be extra
alert on that when they are talking look
at the screen and when you are talking
look at the camera what people often do
is they look atsel when we are
constantly assessing our own nonverbals
it's really tiring and it's really
cognitively demanding and draining so it
creates what's called Zoom fatigue and
that will affect our nonverbals because
we're going to show fatigue we're going
to show disinterest in essence the rules
are the same the important thing is that
you understand that you have to be extra
alert of your body language because
there's no room for
interpretations the goal of any
interview as the interviewer is
information elicitation as the
interviewee is to show confidence
competence and Trust you're going to
create a conversation with that person
or you're going to ask questions as well
or you will have examples that really
apply to it you want to make the other
person feel comfortable you want to make
them feel that you are someone to be
trusted how did this person dress up are
your clothes clean or do you have food
on your clothes I mean I'm I'm relaying
here what I've heard from HR they're
assessing you because you're going to be
representing me we may have a great
brand name but it's your face your
present that's going to make that
difference there might be a hundred
people applying for that job if you come
prepared and you have a genuine
interaction with showing that you really
want it there's so much more chance in
that setting than oh I'm just here this
is my resume yeah please hire
me